today's topic the clown nick briss now
today's video is further evidence of how
much of an addictive drug clout is if
you don't know who nick bris is he's a
youtuber who does pick up basketball
games but pretty much all of his
thumbnails and titles revolve around
violence and fighting at these games he
heavily promotes it he talks about how
it really is after a fallout with one of
his teammates it's come out and he's
being exposed for the fact that he has
been faking the fights yes he's been
paying people to come and instigate
things what's worse is that not only has
he been paying people to come start
these fights with him and his teammates
he hasn't told his teammates that he's
been paying these people so they've been
getting in real violence throwing down
with people
smack them ugly ass teeth out your mouth
he literally admitted to me on a
conversation that in the land
he paid the two guys he paid them
to [__] with me
weapons are being drawn all because this
guy wants to make money he's come out
and denied it since and says no i don't
pay people i don't do that unfortunately
for him there's video evidence of him
actually admitting to this
we don't go out to these parks looking
for problems and looking for drama in
[Applause]
[__] i bet we'll trouble up and let's
see what happens and we pulled up we
beat their ass and it made them mad and
it made them want to fight us
well that's it simple
[Music]
it's all love respect i'm still gonna
bring it off his head though
you know we're not going to look and
trying to fight people and [__] but
we're just we want to bring that energy
and he brings energy we brought the
energy
[Music]
i'm peacemaker in this video man
hey listen everyone on youtube i'm not
promoting this man look
i'm not out here i don't want to be
remembered for the wrong reasons i don't
want to be you know what i mean looked
at the wrong way you guys could clearly
see man in this video
i want to make it clear you know this
keeps happening and you know it's the
first time it happened but if it happens
more and more i'm i'm have to chill on
the way i go about my content because
clearly some of you guys are thinking
that oh they're coming now that's all
right nah man we want to go hard we want
to play good aggressive basketball and
we want to keep it basketball
i mean bro like i planted two characters
that land video where it was me you
carlos and uh iman and akeem played with
us bro like i put two guys out there
that were just talking [__] the whole
time bro you won't respond with them
that was really yeah bro those were fake
characters bro like nobody knew it
i've known about this look at the date
hey look at the date
the date is
september 8th on this video bro did you
see that video on my page where i dunked
on that dude like two years ago and he
chased me around the ship
yeah
that's fake as [__] dude
like bro i know how to get this [__]
done the right way bro for real through
i'm not even trying to like flex i
thought you were a baby
this gangster [__] is real
guys
i'm not a gangster
i'm not
this gangster [__] is real
[__] that are around gangsters
real gangsters
don't do [__] like that
it's not a game
basketball is
but even basketball there's some people
that take it it's their life when we say
ball is life
don't don't don't play like that some
people it's all they got
it's all they got
when it's trying to play with violence
like that and with what they got and you
start insulting people
we're from an era where you stepped on
someone jays
in the club
and it would have been a rap
for something that you didn't intended
to do
now what you did was to me exactly the
same thing as like yo let's do something
real funny i'm gonna pay you you go step
on this [__] jace you don't know
what's gonna happen b
how deep this [__] is rolling
i don't know if it's because this
generation hasn't seen [__] or the scene
that the [__] they seen was in movies
i've seen [__]
and i'm not posting like yeah i've seen
[__] you know no
i'm not happy i've seen what i've seen
i'm not happy i've seen [__]
gets cracked like that
people
dying people get stabbed shot pepper
spray tasered
bottled up
i'm not happy about that [__]
but when you see that [__]
that [__] stays with you bro
stop playing
when you [__] see that [__] and you
got people working under you
and they get hurt
because you wanted to be a gangster
one of my dudes that was working the
door got stabbed in the neck with a
[__] pen
stop
playing this ain't jokes
people live this [__] every day
whatever your intentions were clout
whatever whatever whatnot it's not a
[__] game
it makes me think of all these guys that
do pranks it's just a prank bro it's
just a prank bro don't [__] play
how many people have died doing just a
prank don't [__] play
there's people that really have lives
and they're really dealing with some
[__] and they don't want to deal
with yours
don't play
what's coming to you you don't want it
you don't want it you know what the
worst part is
cowards are dangerous to everyone but
themselves yup
yup think about this right when he set
up the other youtuber not knowing his
past the other youtuber swings knocks
the guy out [__] him up
that could be his life derailed no
and
that i go back and look at y'all
what else to do with a swung on me bro
what if the dude wasn't a uh um a
supporter a fan you know
what a dude really had hate
you know like
you don't know
how much
you put me at risk how much i'm
jeopardizing you know
like how much meditation i have put in
throughout the years how much therapy
sessions i had went to to control my
anger you know
um
and
huh how'd you have flashbacks like bro
that dude would have swung bro like i
would have blacked out like
great content for him make a lot of
money somebody else is that when you
associate with cowards they [__] your
life from yeah also think about the
message you're putting out to other
people about this behavior [__] i'm
not mad at aggressivity at a basketball
game okay especially pick up that's the
game i'm not mad at people talking a lot
of [__] that's the game but you trying
to start all these fights for clicks and
videos that's a different thing
don't play with violence i don't know
how many times we have to tell people
this all it takes is for you guys to
mention enough time and guess what
sometimes a [__] shows up at
your door he doesn't break in but he
opens it don't don't don't play with
that don't play with that cause a
[__] getting stabbed
[__] getting shot [__]
getting hurt you can't edit that nope
that's in your memory that's in your
brain forever you can't edit that and
how you gonna talk about this gangster
persona talk about about it about it but
you quick to call the cops really dude
and y'all [__] with this guy
really
he's a real one to you guys again
there's another one of these of the
blind leading the blind there's a bunch
of fraudsters who for anything will say
the most wild stuff online because it
gets them clicks right you saw it with
this is like that takashi 69 thing where
he rolled up on the bexel's club
yo i let my my nuts hang
i let my nuts hang ain't that what he
was always saying yeah then the fbi came
up he said i pulled my nuts up a lot of
these dudes
are starting to write checks
and i think the last part goes to the
audience we also have to be
more accountable for the kind of content
we encourage the reason why these people
do this kind of lame [__] to seek clout
is because we often choose to click on
it
when you feed into this kind of drama
thing right when you feed into this
stuff and you say this is what i want i
need more of this even though this is
fake and fraudulent and you know all
that stuff
when you feed into that
it just encourages people to start this
stuff for money
[Music]
me
is
[Music]
a